une
on ne sort pas du redoutable navires
dont on ne sort pas indemne
on peut y rentrer des idées préconçues
on n'en ressort pas tout à fait comme on
y rentrer
ce redoutable qui est arrivé ici en juin
2000 pour le
le public d'abord c'est le premier sous
marin nucléaire français lancé par le
général de gaulle en mars 1967 et
construit à cherbourg puisque en gros
depuis 120 ans cherbourg l'arsenal de
cherbourg construit les sous-marins
français et notamment les sous marins
nucléaires
le redoutable arrivant en fin de vie il
ya eu cette proposition de l'état
français de la marine nationale pour
implanter le redoutable ici
[Musique]
de souhaiter que le public puisse
comprendre ce qu'est la vie à bord comme
en cent trente ans à vivre dans des
patrouilles de 70 jours sous la mer sans
remonter à la surface
comment vivaient-ils rip du jour de la
nuit comment vit-il les travaux comment
le sous-marin gère l'acoustique
commentent-ils à quelle distance comment
comment surtout n'est-il pas repéré par
les autres sous marins donc là cette
notion de traçabilité du bruit je suis à
la place du commandant est-ce qu'il faut
que ces lumières sont rouges 24 mais il
ya des
les gens font les trois huit et donc
pour recréer un cycle jour nuit en fait
il ya des lumières normal que des
lumières rouges comme ça
[Musique]
vous sentez pas mais se sent comme chez
mes grands parents soit en espèces deux
de renforcer sans les aides de 63 et
c'est particulier donc ici on est dans
la cafétaria tard lieu de rencontre des
changes
et le cuisiner c'est un peu la star du
croire forcément parfait des bons petits
plats
il mange des repas spéciaux pour le
réveillon par exemple les gens qui sont
à bord du sous-marin les sous-mariniers
ne passent pas leur temps à travailler
en c'est normal et c'est vraiment très
très fort leur routage un extrait du
sport abord parce que forcément il
construit par enfant un maquis footing
la musculation aussi
il ya c'est comme un petit monde en fait
et puis aussi des oiseaux
[Musique]
où
alors les loisirs aujourd'hui je ne sais
rien à l'époque du redoutable
il y avait un grand écran qu'on pouvait
sortir le dimanche
le soir au fond - le dimanche ne pas
chasser le grand patron de ce souverain
m'a dit parce qu'on est quand même avec
soixante dix les tontons flingueurs
bernard blier lino ventura et haute en a
quand même on en a mangé pas mal voilà
mais il y avait aussi des soirées où il
y avait des jeux de société il y avait
parfois si un musicien accordéoniste
guitariste était à l'époque embarquer
dans les soutes marié va y avait ce soir
et idra
[Musique]
où
parce qu'on voit sous nos pieds là c'est
assez impressionnant en fait c'est le
cabinet médical
c'est à dire qu'il y avait un médecin à
bord
et puis soignées en général des petits
bobos parce que les gens qui venaient
souvent devait quand même avant
en physique a cité ces quantités mais le
moindre petit bobo été soigné parce que
forcément
marys qe2 voilà et apparemment il ya
même un marin qui a une densité qui a
été opérée sur place parce que forcément
on peut pas rentrer
[Musique]
l' équilibre de l'équipage équipe
psychologique est déterminant
déterminant c'est ce qui fait d'ailleurs
que le médecin à bord cathy des
compétences en matière chirurgicale
légère et puis les dents mais qui a
aussi fait des coupes et en cadets
compétition psychologie
je crois mon petit gars tri quelque part
il est le confesseur voilà c'est lui qui
assure avec le pacha l'equilibre aussi
de toussaint 6 et dans une communauté de
destin qui par 70 jours qui séparent
ouellet qui sait pas où elle va c'est
quand même assez particulier
[Musique]
la pièce maîtresse
m
oh
[Musique]
avec dj missill je sais que chaque
missile balistique était plus puissante
que hiroshima et que ben ça n'a jamais
servi la force nucléaire stratégiques
elle s'appuie sur une théorie alors que
l'on admet que l'on admet pan ké la
stratégie de la dissuasion
c'est la doctrine de la peur c'est à
dire tous en face mon ami tu veux pas
m'attaquer
parce que si tu m'attaques la réponse va
être dévastatrices je laisse à chacun la
réflexion et c'est pour ça que
d'ailleurs dans le parcours nous parlons
de très peu de ces enjeux nous c'est
surtout la ville et chant 30 hommes
[Musique]